[Music]
this morning on the dish a trip to a
place where food is usually frowned upon
the museum but that is hardly the case
at a relatively new institution in
brooklyn new york
the museum of food and drink was founded
to showcase culinary traditions from
across the globe while
educating visitors about the cultures
they come from
and now mofad is facing a new challenge
to continue its mission
in the virtual world this is the most
amount i've ever cooked in my home
ever it was the perfect pairing an
online food conversation and
demonstration with famed israeli-born
chef michael salmanov
and his friend and fellow cookbook
author now based in israel
adina sussman it might have been like 2
a.m for her
in all fairness whenever we hang out
together in tel aviv it's usually 2
o'clock in the morning anyways
their hangout this time had a few more
involved let's talk about spices
including a virtual audience to have
something that
brings a little bit of purpose and sort
of brings it back to what we do in our
life that matters the people in our life
that matter
you know that was like really the
opportunity food is something at least
right now that's still bringing us
together isn't it
food definitely is and i think we have
this opportunity to have these
sort of interactions that are like in a
way public but also span different
continents at the same time
israeli pantry staples as the program
was called was put together by the
museum of food and drink
they talked about you know quarantine
cooking and their middle eastern pantry
staples
and chef mike demonstrated his
five-minute hummus so what we're going
to make first is a cleaner sauce
and we're going to spin it hey everyone
mike is doing his thing with the food
processor siri cayman is the program
director for the five-year-old museum of
food and drink or mofad
oh that looks good its goal using food
to educate
inspire and bring people together the
purpose is to show that
food is culture it's not just about
cooking classes and it's not just about
eating at restaurants we are really
interested in
telling the stories of food sharing the
history
contextualizing food mofad started as a
mobile exhibition
expanded into a 5 000 square foot
interactive space in brooklyn
and then while in the process of
relocating came
covid 19. so how did you guys pivot
once the pandemic hit and you knew you
had to do something different
it was very challenging and really
overwhelming my concern at first
everybody was pivoting to online and
there was so much content happening
and then it just became apparent that
actually this was an opportunity
to even grow our community once you
reopen like as operators what what
what changes are going to come first i
mean it's
impossible to say really mofad first
looked within its own community
giving an amplified online voice to
those in the industry looking to help
others
like greg backstrom of olmsted in
brooklyn they were
kind enough to put us on their platform
to help inform people
to spread the word that we have a food
bank and that if anyone needs it you
know to come
you said you learned also from it what
did you learn in that
in the experience well just you know
that we're not alone that there's a lot
of support there's a lot of good will
out there
you want to peel your peers so it should
look something like this by connecting
food creators and food lovers from
around the world virtually
mofad expanded its base in ways never
envisioned
all visitors need a computer or
smartphone and they're transported to
online cooking classes
you can see that it's not the sauce
sitting on top of the pasta and
even dinner parties we're giving them
recipes we're giving them boxes of
ingredients they can order
a way to sort of cook together even if
we're not together and then at least we
all sit down
at the same time and connect online it's
in
those moments that mofad found food can
also be a gateway to conversation about
the issues of the day
this is a new series like racism against
asian americans during the pandemic
so we've had a couple different panel
conversations sort of contextualizing it
to food so we've talked about chinese
restaurants the survival of restaurants
and chinatowns
food taboos as they relate to xenophobia
and our own cultural bias
but what have you found in some of these
conversations you know i think it's
difficult
the younger restaurateurs are coming in
and trying to give support and help
these older restaurants
find means to innovate and strategize
right now so that they don't have to
shut their doors but
it's a really difficult situation we use
food as a lens to understand
ourselves each other and the world
around us catherine pickley is the
acting president of the museum of food
and drink
food also is something that brings
people together of different backgrounds
how important is that right now i think
that's incredibly important i'm going to
butcher this quote but
i think that leah chase said something
along the lines of you know we all
gather together
at the table and we talk and we can
change the world
i think that's really really true that's
the power of food
a power that even before the black lives
matter's protests began
mofad hoped would help tell the story of
the african-american contribution to our
country's food history
its exhibit african american making the
nation's table
had its opening postponed by the
pandemic we
are exploring ways that we can open the
exhibition virtually
you know how do we get this larger
community than we ever had before
able to really see these stories and
begin to
uncover history that was lost
or not told mofad is at its heart a
little bit of an activist organization
it's uncovering these inequities and
saying come together come together
around this thing that you love
should we be reheating call it mofad's
recipe for success from the very start
food is culture and ancestry and
advocacy and it's where you come from
it's part of what you are it's your
memories it's conflict it's commonality
it's all those things
so obviously a museum sort of to
celebrate that or to have a discussion
about that is is
of the utmost importance and i know we
said it a lot in the piece but it's the
thing that brings us together and it is
a place where you can have difficult
conversations because you are gathering
around it can't bring us together in the
same way inside restaurants right now
unfortunately but it was fun to look at
all the food we're both hungry
and to talk about celebrating food